in 2019 elita battle angel
a gorgeous cyberpunk adventure was
unleashed upon the world
featuring a wide-eyed cyborg in a
corrupt world
this visually packed film lends itself
to re-watching
in fact there are some things you might
only notice after a second viewing
and we're here to revisit those moments
the dystopian 26th century setting of
elita battle angel
comes complete with a floating sky city
killer sports
advanced robotics and even a bit of
chocolate
that's so great however hundreds of
years of technological advancement
have blurred the line between human and
machine by the time elita steps out onto
the bustling streets of iron city
you've probably already acclimated to
the cgi heavy details of her design
cybernetic limb replacements are
commonplace in this world
in fact many of the characters are so
heavily modified
that the only organic component left in
them seems to be their brains
as more characters enter the fray
viewers don't even realize on their
first watch of the film
that there might actually be more cgi
enhanced figures than there are plain
old human actors
excluding the innumerable extras
wandering around in the background
few elita characters aren't part machine
by the time we reach the finale
even elita's love interest hugo
eventually has his head transferred to a
cyborg body
the movie's ability to pull you into
this cyberpunk reality is thanks to its
top-notch cgi
that's not a surprise considering the
talent and experience behind the film
james cameron the film's producer and
co-screenwriter
worked on the spectacular visuals for
more than a decade
the central metaphor in elita is blatant
the human elite
live in the floating city of salem and
dump their trash
into the city below where the rest of
humanity lives
most of iron city's population is either
desperately trying to scrape by or
working feverishly to move to the city
above
elita is repeatedly told that no one
ever ascends to life in xalam
despite people's belief in the
possibility it just doesn't seem to
happen
however the cargo tubes that ship
materials up to xalam
seem to be a viable way of sneaking in
the prospect even comes up in
conversation
but is dismissed when hugo informs elita
about the world around her
he describes the tubes as meant for
cargo not people and the topic doesn't
come up again
while the concept of sneaking into xalam
through a cargo tube seems pretty
obvious
it must be extremely hazardous whatever
future gizmo
zips cargo around could probably crush a
human or a cyborg body
also it might be pressurized in some
lethal way but our vast knowledge of
heist movies has us thinking there are
more possibilities here than hugo might
realize
however after hugo has his cyborg body
he tackles the tubes from another angle
and decides to just walk on top of one
all the way to xalum
unfortunately he didn't expect his
stroll to be cut tragically short by
spinning blades of death
elita's introduction into the world of
the hunter warrior arrives thanks to her
scrapyard rescuer
dr dyson ido in order to satisfy the
pain he feels over his daughter's death
the doctor has registered with the
factory as a hunter warrior
he roams the streets at night defeating
vicious criminals in exchange for bounty
payments to fund his clinic
his weapon of choice is a rocket hammer
a gigantic blunt weapon with a rocket at
one end
that propels the device through its
target we only see the doctor fight
briefly in one skirmish before elita
jumps in
and dismantles his opponents with ease
if she hadn't been there though
we find it difficult to believe it would
have been successful with his cumbersome
weapon
the criminals in the alley are all
cyborgs and ido manages to knock off one
of their
limbs with his rocket hammer but after
this blow he stumbles while trying to
wield his massive weapon again
unless edo has spent years with a 100
success rate on his first fatal blow
it's hard to imagine that the kindly
doctor has the strength speed
and agility to be a successful hunter
warrior honestly
the poor guy can't even navigate through
a crowd without running into an innocent
bystander
given the impoverished citizens of iron
city's access to cybernetics
there must be some truly extraordinary
gadgets being used in xalam
we never truly see what life is like up
there but we do get a few details that
paint a vivid picture the fact that dr
edo
and dr shurin were forced into exile
because of their daughter's disease
indicates that death is shunned up there
in fact
nova's words spoken through his puppets
indicate access to outright immortality
just before elita thrusts her blade
through vector nova's voice creeps
through him to say
i found the only way to enjoy
immortality
is to watch others die on a first watch
the viewer is processing so much
information that this detail might slip
by without much notice
this line immediately follows the thug
gruwishka's defeat
and shortly after the reveal of dr
shurin's disassembled body
but a re-watch allows its implications
to sink in
as do elita's memories when they return
to her
they reveal that 300 years earlier she
was already battling nova
zalim residents seem to have access to
technology so advanced
they can achieve immortality while
maintaining much of their physical
humanity
meanwhile iron city's population is
forced to fuse their battered bodies
with whatever bits of old tech they can
scrounge up
while exploring the underwater wreckage
of a spaceship outside of iron city
elita finds a superior body which
possesses
lost technology from the united republic
of mars
initially ito refuses to attach elita to
this body
but after she's sliced apart in battle
he gives in
thus elita is fused with the berserker a
body of immense power and skill
when elite awakens in her new form she
shows off by executing a graceful
handstand
on her index finger after writing
herself she notices an intake flow on
her shoulder that generates arc plasma
at her finger it seems like an
unimportant if very cool
detail on a first watch one you might
assume is a nod to the original manga
but after seeing how everything plays
out towards the end of the film
you'll realize this device's true
purpose
after elita relieves the hunter warrior
zapan
of the ancient damascus blade she
displays the ability to engulf the
entire weapon
in a glowing plasma it is that little
blue flame
which she can now generate that pumps
power into the sword
and allows her to slice through
sentinels like butter
three centuries after the fall an
ultra-violent spore
called motorball dominates iron city
every kid grows up playing the sport
albeit with a little less death involved
elita is introduced to the game by hugo
and plays with the neighborhood kids
while learning how it all works
at its core motorball comes down to ball
possession and scoring
after watching the movie a couple times
however we're starting to think
scoring takes a back seat being the last
one standing
at least on the professional level when
we see a pro motorball match in action
some players do appear to chase the
elusive ball but many other players seem
to ignore it
interested only in ripping through their
opponents with whatever new age weaponry
the league has deemed legal
and if we're being honest we wouldn't
have it any other way
motorball without carnage would just be
robots on rollerblades
the grand arena is a place for these
futuristic gladiators to flex their
might
and satiate the public's lust for
violence
if they happen to toss that wonky ball
into the goal while shredding their
machine bodies
well that makes for extra bragging
rights but it really seems that the
point here
is to make it through the match without
getting your head ripped off
[Music]
the most obvious scene in elita battle
angel that points to a sequel
is nova's menacing reveal at the end of
the film
however there are numerous other details
hidden throughout the movie that hint
towards additional plots ripe for
expansion
one of the biggest occurs when elita is
being shown around the motorball track
by hugo when she asks who the best
player in the game
is hugo responds by saying that joshugen
is on track to be champion for less than
10 seconds
attention turns to the motorball player
in question as he receives repairs
it happens so quickly you might not
notice that joshugin
is played by jai courtney star of
suicide squad
divergent and terminator genesis an
actor known for his work in other
blockbuster franchises
is a nod to more being in store for this
character
in an interview with business insider he
recalled a conversation
he had with the film's director robert
rodriguez corning said
rodriguez called me up when they were in
production and said
there's this role it's a little small on
paper but if this thing blows up
i'll need someone who i can rely on when
we revisit it
that definitely tells us rodriguez has
much more in mind for courtney
should an elita sequel get the green
light
the seedy underbelly of iron city is run
by a man named vector
and his power stems from his corruption
of professional motorball
vector holds sway over the game's odds
by tweaking the player's power
going so far as to hire naive youth to
abduct and rob cyborgs of their limbs
his direct connection to xalam enables
such manipulation
he uses this relationship to make those
around him believe
he has the power to send people to the
floating city vector
dangles this promise in front of his
lackeys until they wise up and decide
they've had enough
it's at this moment that he fulfills his
end of the bargain and sends them to
zalem
albeit not in the way they'd hoped of
course if you've only watched elita once
you might not have latched on to this
detail
one example is when dr shurin decides to
quit her position
and vector tells her don't you think
it's time you want to zone
and i can send you up there right now
the next time we see shurin is after
elita crashes into
vector's office he says that he always
keeps his promises to send people to
xalam
just like dr shurin unfortunately he
then
opens up a chest revealing her brain and
other parts
ready to make its journey to the city in
the sky nova demands body parts for his
experiments and as vector says
that is the only way anyone gets to
xalam
there are a couple rules regarding what
weapons are allowed in the motorball
arena
but they're pretty lacks in fact after
watching the movie a few times you can't
help but notice how the sport transcends
the laws of iron city at large
guns are outlawed here hugo lays it all
out when informing elita
about weapons and the sword being
carried by zepan
all guns are outlawed in iron city
punishable by death
the need for unique weapons among the
hunter warriors makes sense
given this stipulation but what's with
all the deadly projectiles used by the
competitors in motorball
when elita is being chased down by an
entire team of bloodthirsty challengers
hellbent on placing her head on a pike
one of them fires a cannon at her
causing a massive explosion that knocks
elita off her feet
now we immediately picture bullet firing
pistols in regards to the no guns policy
but rocket launchers really seem like
they should fall into that illegal
category as well
the announcer of the match can be heard
mentioning legality and regulations
during the matches
but we're left thinking that might just
be for show
since the canon forms one player's
entire gigantic arm
the laws of iron city seem to be pretty
flexible
when elita displays the strength of her
new berserker body
dr ito has an appropriate response a
warrior's spirit needs a warrior's body
the synergy elita has with her new body
is indeed remarkable
the body boasts miraculous
nanotechnology once elita is attached to
the berserker
the entire system synchronizes with her
mind and begins making adjustments to
better represent her sense of self
this characteristic is subtly put on
display again
during the closing moments of the film
compared to how her berserker form
appears when she's first attached to it
the body that viewers are shown later is
much more attuned to combat
this hints at what elita has been
through in the months after hugo's death
chiefly she's fought her way through the
motorball league which is no
easy task thus her body is changed to
reflect her circumstances
it's a literal adaptation but also a
reflection
of elita's inner nature and her
boundless potential
you can't help but wonder what other
forms she might be able to take
perhaps in a sequel if fans of the film
get their wish
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss
a single one
[Music]